mass is just trapped energy we like to
think a ball like this has mass because
it exists when in reality it has mass
because of what's happening to it or at
least what's happening to its tiniest
Parts protons and neutrons are mostly
just gluons and those gluons don't have
any Mass themselves but they can give
Mass to anything they're trapped inside
like a proton or a neutron if light is
bouncing around inside a box of mirrors
that light adds to the mass of the Box
even though the light doesn't have mass
a stretched spring has more mass than a
relaxed one a hot pan has more mass than
a cool one a charged battery has more
mass than a dead one that's what the
equation E equals MC squared means